Hello Freak bitches.
I'm telling you man,
just looking at that thing right there
when you're talking about the guy hasn't
done standup in forever and he just goes
up there and murders it like that and is
in perfect form.
His timing is perfect.
He's a fucking fantastic standup.
Such a talent,
Huh?
Amazing.
Unbelievable.
Crazy run to again now.
Huh?
I see him all the time.
I see on your instagram.
Yeah.
We hang out at the comedy store all the
time.
She was always there.
He took me some eyes wide shut party in
the middle of the Hollywood hills.
We had a.
You had to get in an elevator and go to
the top of this hill.
Yeah,
it was Naomi Campbell had his birthday
party and so dave's like,
hey joe,
you want to go with me to this party?
And I'm like,
dude,
I don't,
I don't like going to those parties.
I like avoiding celebrity things.
Like,
oh come on man,
I got to be back here by midnight.
Anyway,
I go,
all right.
So we're looking crazy amounts of weed.
Fuck,
we uh,
we get my portion will go up to the top
of this hill,
get even more baked,
go get,
get in a shuttle that takes you up to
this dude's house.
And some dude who has the sickest house
at the top of the Hollywood hill.
It's just some crazy billionaire
character who has a sick house.
And then above his sick house he has a
sick party house type.
He has just a party house.
So you go to the top of this house and
he has this fucking insane view of the
city where it looks like blade runner,
you know,
and he's got one 80 degrees of windows.
His party house is like a,
like a flying saucer that just got stuck
in the side of a building.
But the whole outside edge of the flying
saucer is all windows.
So you're sitting there with all seats
around the windows and then he has his
big bar and he hasn't.
I mean the guy's just closes all loaded
with the.
And we have to take an elevator,
like a foreperson elevator openair
elevator that goes up the side of the
hill.
And as we're going up the side of the
hill and Naomi Campbell's naked photo is
40,
50 feet tall and I'm not kidding,
I'm not exaggerating,
it's just enormous naked photo of Naomi
Campbell.
And then we get up to the top and it's
like fucking demean Moore's there.
And I'm saying hi to Lenny Kravitz.
I'm like,
this is so strange.
So high last barbecue barbecued,
so,
so high.
Shouldn't be out in public and up there
with all these fucking super rich
people.
I'm like,
what's up lenny?
Hey,
what's up man?
How you doing?
We're talking to Lenny Kravitz.
Like how bizarre is this just seems.
Yeah,
it seems really nice.
But it was all these.
I was talking to these musicians dudes
about mma.
It was like I got cornered by all these
musicians.
Started throwing up fighting this.
Oh my God,
man.
Dude.
People get so excited.
He gets so excited.
They want to start talking mma.
I've got a guy who knows.
Got Meanwhile,
I'm like anything to relax my anxiety
right now.
I'll tell you all the shit I wake up,
write down whatever the fuck you want.
Fighters who you know who's gonna win 17
schedule,
he was with the part about it,
like there was one point in the night.
No,
Campbell is for a book that she has a
book coming out and for.
She's very nice too,
by the way.
Super Nice and beautiful timepiece.
One hundred percent.
I don't know how old she is.
She's got to be 40,
right?
I would imagine.
I say closer to 50.
Really?
Yeah,
because it on the backside.
Crawford is 50 now.
I think she's 49.
I think she's a little older than that.
I think she's.
She's,
she's,
she's Naomi Campbell.
40 five.
How old is Cindy Crawford?
She's probably still just turned 15.
Noemi Campbell.
40 five.
Still fucking slamming hot.
Right.
So anyway,
she stops in the middle of this thing.
They have this,
they have these photos of her.
Her book is out and it's this exclusive
book that cost like 1500 bucks or
something like that to that much.
Really big,
high glossy.
The whole deal.
Don't.
She just stops and they start taking
photos over and she just starts posing.
So no one talks.
No one's taught like everyone is just
watching because it's Naomi Campbell
party,
so it's almost like Michael Bolton gets
out of his party and starts shaking my
cell phone,
but it's like that.
She's doing her thing posing crap.
That's how amazing go and there's just.
It was a kind of a fascinating little
party.
It was a good thing to dip my toe into
it and get the fuck out of there as
quickly as realize why you don't go to
those.
Yeah,
well it's just,
it's they're too famous to famous and
it's,
it's what it is is to me.
It's like,
Ooh,
don't get that famous for sure.
Back off if you didn't get weird.
Well,
everybody gets weird.
It's weird.
They're weird people when they have to
hang out with each other because nobody
else is gonna understand.
You know that I was talking to Dave
about that.
I go,
do you like hanging out with
celebrities?
Because they're the only people that
understand what your lives are.
He's like,
Oh man,
but I'm not as famous as them.
I go hit the brakes.
I go,
Dad's party problem.
Yup.
You don't understand how fucking famous
you are.
The most famous comedians that's ever
lived and one of the most famous
celebrities in America,
like if there's a 100 list of the most
famous people in America in chapels on
that.
I'm not on that list.
I like to stay on the outskirts,
that list.
I like to be in the suburbs that I don't
know Joe.
Oh,
I think you're in that world,
but I'm definitely not.
Definitely so right now you're closing
in on.
You ain't quitting.
Slowing down,
slowing down and thinking about moving
to like Yosemite,
which you do that both with Eva.